vous l'appelez vous à ce moment-là vous
l'avez au téléphone et vous vous lui
dites est-ce que c'est toi qui a fait le
cours tout à fait et là il vous répond
non
depuis 6 mois le Stuart français Michael
Philippe et retenu aux USA en attendant
son procès il avait découvert dans les
toilettes d'un avion des messages
d'alerte à la bombe et des messages de
soutien à Ben Laden du coup les
États-Unis le considèrent désormais
comme un terroriste son père appelle à
l'aide voici François Philippe alors
François Philippe donc vous habitez
Aix-les-Bains vous êtes quincaillé et
conseillé municipal votre fils Michael
est né en 1976 quand il était adolescent
le décor de sa chambre témoignait d'une
d'une véritable passion pour les
États-Unis il avait un drapeau américain
dans sa chambre tout à fait et
d'ailleurs à l'adolescence quelques
temps plus tard il est parti au moins
deux fois par an aux USA voir un oncle
qui qui travaille là-bas
alors quand vous lui parliez des
États-Unis à la maison vous lui parliez
d'un pays liberté d'un pays de réussite
vous êtes toujours donné une image très
positive des États-Unis tout à fait
alors à 23 ans son BTS en poche votre
fils travaille à Air France service des
valises perdues et ensuite il devient
Stewart dans la compagnie Virgin
Atlantique qui réussit très bien il est
deuxième sur 170 il travaille là-bas
pendant deux ans il ne recueille on peut
le dire je crois que des éloges n'ont
été très appréciés par ces patrons c'est
ça tout à fait d'ailleurs on a de
nombreuses lettres et de passagers et de
sa compagnie pour témoigner de la chose
le 11 septembre il l'a vécu d'une façon
assez assez dramatique il a été
bouleversé par ce qui s'est passé au
World Trade Center et il organisé avec
ses collègues une collecte pour tout à
fait des des vêtements de la nourriture
au sauveteur tout à fait tout à fait
et puis le 19 janvier Michael prend son
service sur le vol Londres Orlando en
Floride vol pénible parce qu'il y a 150
adolescents sur 358 passagers c'est des
adolescents qui vont à Disneyland tout à
fait Orlando
et pas réputé ou visitable parce qu'il y
a relativement peu de choses et la
plupart des des
attractions d'Orlando c'est Disney et
trois heures après le décollage il
inspecte les toilettes et il découvre
sur le miroir des toilettes une
inscription Ben Laden et le meilleur
tous les Américains doivent mourir voilà
écrit avec du savon liquide c'est ça
tout à fait sur le sur le miroir et puis
il y a un sac en papier aussi qui est
glissé dans un interstice des toilettes
sur lequel il est écrit il y a une bombe
à bord voilà
alors qu'est-ce qu'il fait votre fille
s'il avertit le commandant de bord alors
d'abord je pense qu'il y a il applique
la procédure c'est-à-dire qu'avant de
prévenir le commandant de bord il faut
qu'il ait la teneur du message et la
qualité du message donc
voyons le message quand le miroir il met
le doigt dessus pour voir effectivement
ce que c'était et pour lire le message
qui était à l'envers il retire le sac de
mal de l'air pour lire le message il
remet en place tous les indices et
seulement après
comme le dit le règlement il prévient le
commandant de bord voilà alors l'avion
se pose à Reykjavik en Islande où il
sera inspecté pendant 22 heures tout à
fait alors rien à signaler on repart
mais il y a quand même trois personnes
qui avaient pris un autre avion qui
reprennent pas l'avion oui
est-ce qu'on a une trace à aucune non
puis le FBI cherche pas d'ailleurs alors
voilà deux mois passent Michael votre
fils s'effectue 5 vols entre l'Europe et
les États-Unis sans problème aucun
problème
et pourtant le 27 mars dernier il est
arrêté à l'aéroport de New York à côté
de New York il est menotté sans
ménagement devant ses camarades de
travail tout à fait
là il est arrêté
emmener au poste de police de l'aéroport
interroger
sans pouvoir téléphoner ni à l'ambassade
ni aux parents
et c'est seulement le lendemain comme il
a bien collaboré avec le la police
locale pour tous les renseignements
qu'on lui demandaient où il a eu le
droit de passer un coup de téléphone et
c'est là qui m'a prévenu voilà le FBI
soupçonne votre fils d'être l'auteur des
messages terroristes trouvés dans les
toilettes et bien pire on l'accuse de
menaces d'utilisation d'armes de
destruction massive pour anéantir les
États-Unis c'est à peine croyable c'est
totalement fou
alors vous l'appelez vous à ce moment-là
vous l'avez au téléphone et vous vous
lui dites est-ce que c'est toi qui a
fait le cours tout à fait et là il vous
répond non
et vous êtes sûr vous êtes vraiment sûr
que il vous aurait pas raconté
d'histoire non
donc vous partez aux États-Unis
et pour payer la pour payer la caution
250 000 dollars vous avez fait comment
pour les trouver
il faut le tiroir
de la famille
c'est difficile mais on va y arriver
quand même bien sûr de là votre fils
bien sûr alors le FBI avoir des preuves
alors il y a des empreintes sur le sac
en papier ce qui est normal tout à fait
le sac dans l'intercice des toilettes
enfin je dirais déclaré
héritier vite déjà avoir touché le
miroir et pris le papier et puis il y a
une autre empreinte qui est non
identifiée qu'on a du mal à identifier
alors sur le sac de mal de l'air
il y a une empreinte de paume de main
qui est pas du tout celle de Michael et
le FBI fait aucune recherche d'ailleurs
pour chercher à qui ça appartient
bon quant au miroir sur lequel était
écrit ce message terroriste à la bombe
lui il a été nettoyant en Islande
évidemment mais il est quand même bon de
préciser qu'on a fait faire des études
des des études par la police
scientifique et on s'est aperçu que pour
mettre une trace
d'empreintes sur du savon liquide il
faut 13 minutes et ça c'est important
donc c'est en aucun cas le gars qui
écrit le message qui peut laisser son
empreinte
alors il y a eu aussi des analyses
graphologiques alors les énergies
graphologiques le FBI a fait faire une
analyse graphologique elle elle en
déduit que Michael est pas l'auteur de
ces messages mais quand même elle a été
produite au tribunal
nous on a fait faire des des expertises
graphologiques par certainement le
meilleur des États-Unis qui s'appelle
Williams qui est l'ancien patron du
service graphologique du FBI qui lui dit
d'abord c'est pas Mickaël et en plus ici
dans son rapport 3 noms de personnes qui
ont des écritures similaires et trois
noms d'autres personnes qui auraient pu
écrire un message
pas encore assez content d'avoir juste
ça on fait faire une autre étude
graphologique par un second qui est un
peu moins réputé mais bon quand même et
qui dit c'est de toute façon pas Mickaël
alors le juge d'Orlando conclut
effectivement à des évidences
extrêmement légères mais il vous demande
une caution de 500 000 dollars tout à
fait parce que obligé de rajouter 250
000 dollars au premier 250 mille dollars
tout à fait parce que quand
l'explication du juge compte tenu de la
du métier de Michael c'était un sujet à
risque pour rentrer en France
alors votre fils va vivre désormais avec
un bracelet électronique autour du Tour
du poignet un procès est prévu il aura
lieu quand débute l'année prochaine
parce qu'il était prévu le 21 octobre
tout à fait mais il a été repoussé comme
repoussé repousser alors la charge qui
reste contre lui c'est fausse
déclarations au FBI car il a pas reconnu
être l'auteur des graffitis tout à fait
de prison pour mensonge au FBI et
entrave à la justice américaine tout à
fait par contre si vous me permettez
parce qu'il y a des aspects très très
technique de la chose j'aimerais
que mon avocat puisse venir bien sûr
monsieur si vous voulez venir monsieur
maître Maurice bonsoir bonsoir monsieur
drôle d'histoire non c'est une histoire
absolument incroyable parce que
michael est un garçon qui aime les
États-Unis qui a une véritable
vénération pour ce pays qui en plus le
11 septembre est aux États-Unis pour des
raisons professionnelles il va porter de
la nourriture aux Américains il est
photographié avec des gens du FBI sur
place et puis Michael et mêlé alors
qu'il fait son métier de prévenir le
commandant de bord à une véritable
méprise judiciaire à savoir que compte
tenu du climat qui existe aujourd'hui
aux États-Unis car on est véritablement
dans une dans une psychose sécuritaire
et bien on le soupçonne de cela et vous
avez parfaitement noté tout à l'heure
que la charge d'origine est absolument
incroyable c'est-à-dire menace
d'utilisation d'une arme contre les
États-Unis alors malheureusement il y a
d'autres charges qui pèsent désormais
contre lui puisque l'agent du FBI qui
est particulièrement chargé de votre
fils est allé recueillir des témoignages
de prisonniers avec qui il a été enfermé
de CO détenu en fait c'est une prison où
il a passé trois ou quatre nuits mais
en tous les cas il paraît que votre fils
donc d'après ce cet agent du FBI aurait
avoué à ses collègues de Chambray que
les messages étaient de lui
ça fait partie du canevas des des
accusations en question
moi ce qu'il faut savoir aussi c'est
qu'aux États-Unis les prisonniers qui
sont qui font ce type de révélation on
des remises ont des remises de peine et
surtout ceux se place sous la protection
du gouvernement c'est-à-dire qu'on ne
peut pas les attaquer pour faux
témoignages alors que les témoignages
sont manifestement mensongés alors les
mêmes codés tenues ont dit qu'il
prenaient trois grammes de cocaïne par
jour ce qui quand ont besoin dans un
avion quand même elle doit être
difficile qu'il était trafiquant d'armes
qui trafiqué des armes entre les
États-Unis et Israël qu'il était un
agent secret pour la France enfin
effectivement là ça devient complètement
paranoïaque il reste plus que ça comme
on a prouvé que les accusations
précédentes étaient fausses il reste
plus que ces quatre faux témoignages
alors au début Monsieur Philippe vous
faites confiance vous aux institutions
américaines bien entendu mais là à un
moment vous dites trop c'est trop et
vous décidez donc d'aller rencontrer les
autorités de venir en parler ici à la
télévision à Tout le monde en parle
vous espérez quoi maintenant j'espère
tout simplement
que compte tenu de l'énormité de la
grossièreté de de cette affaire qui
n'aime ni que ni tête
les autorités françaises
laissent rentrer mon fils en France en
attendant quand même son procès comment
c'est comporté l'employeur de votre fils
c'est-à-dire la compagnie aérienne
Virgin Atlantique
il est continué à être payé
quand vous allez aux États-Unis vous
payez les billets tout à fait
mais ils ont pas soutenu juridiquement
leur employé Michael Philippe non pas du
tout
il est stressé votre fils comment il va
ouais
ça dure depuis trop trop longtemps
au début on se dit que quand même au
bout d'un mois ou deux ils vont se
rendre compte quand même que c'est mais
là sept mois
ça va
il prend des trucs des antidépresseurs
des choses comme ça
alors évidemment on cherche une
explication à tout ça c'est tellement
étrange alors au début on se dit qu'il
est coupable et puis on se dit quand
même bon pourquoi il serait allé faire
ça dans cet avion effectivement c'est
peu croyable ensuite on se dit
effectivement qu'il est victime de la
phobie sécurité qui règne aux États-Unis
depuis les attentats du 11 septembre et
puis on se dit aussi surtout qu'il y a
aux États-Unis en ce moment un climat
anti-français
joker
je vous comprends
on peut faire quoi pour vous aider
maître Maurice peut vous le dire je
crois que ce qu'il faut quand même
signaler c'est que le Président de la
République Jacques Chirac a demandé au
secrétaire général de l'unité de nous
recevoir nous avons été reçus très
longuement pendant une heure et demie
parce que
manifestement c'est un dossier qui a
tiré l'attention du Président si vous
voulez on a l'impression dans cette
affaire que si jamais l'opinion publique
française ne s'élève pas face à la
situation qui est celle de Michael et
bien il ne reviendra pas en France avant
d'être jugé et ce qu'il faut comprendre
c'est qu'il va être jugé par un jury
populaire tout dépend de l'humeur du
jury populaire le jour où il juge et
est-ce que vous devez savoir parce que
c'est très important c'est que Michael
devait être jugé initialement les 9 10
et 11 septembre c'est à dire que pendant
son procès une minute de silence aurait
été si vous voulez manifester en
solidarité par rapport aux événements
qui se sont passés et que nous
connaissons tous donc je sais pas si
vous vous percevez le poids qu'il y a
actuellement dans cette affaire contre
Michael
va vous aider oui
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu